les faits donc ont eu lieu hier soir
l'info est tombée ce matin via un
communiqué de l'elysée à 9h42 deux
hélicoptères entrés en collision dans le
centre est du mali dans la région de
ménaka
la suite est évoqué avec beaucoup
d'émotion par le chef d'état major des
armées le général françois lecointre
des hélicoptères sont là en mission de
reconnaissance de nuit dans des
conditions de combat et des conditions
opérationnelles très exigeante pour
repérer ce pick up qui s'enfuit vers le
nord est
au moment où cette opération de
reconnaissance de nuit est en train de
se faire les commandos parachutistes qui
sont au sol entendu une explosion vers
18h30 8 et pense que cette explosion est
due
ces deux explosions sont dus à une
collision en vol entre deux appareils à
voir mais si on veut confirmer
rapidement après par le tigre qui reste
en vol et qui confirme qu'il ya eu
collision entre le couguar les l'un des
deux tigres je voudrais comme l'a fait
la ministre andres hommage à nos
compagnons à leur famille à tous leurs
frères d'armes qui sont encore engagés
au combat aujourd'hui et à leurs chefs
est ce que chacun d'eux se sont
forcément comptable de la vie de chacun
de ses hommes
et c'est donc le l'accident le plus le
plus tragique depuis 36 ans dans l'armée
française le nombre l'hécatombe
la plus la plus forte depuis 36 ans
depuis notamment l'embuscade d'uzbin ans
le 18 juin 2002 18 août pardon en 2008
et puis également depuis le drame
l'accident dramatique d'albacete en
espagne en janvier 2015 ou encore le
crash d'un hélicoptère avec des forces
spéciales à bord en janvier 2009
des minutes de silence ont été
organisées à l'assemblée l'émotion était
intense notamment au sénat où on a
appris la mort d'un élu pire du fils
d'un élu par dampierre bockel fils de
l'ancien secrétaire d'état à la
coopération puis à la défense de nicolas
sarkozy qui est lui-même colonel de
réserve jean marie bockel
je vous propose d'écouter à cet égard le
début de l'hommage d'ailleurs de gérard
larcher
mes chers collègues
c'est avec une extrême tristesse et une
très vive émotion que nous avons appris
la disparition treize militaires
français survenu au mali la nuit
dernière dans une collision
d'hélicoptère au cours d'une action de
combat dans le cadre de l'opération
barkan oddo russe iana tout entier je
veux saluer le courage et l'abnégation
de ces militaires de l'armée de terre
six officiers six sous-officiers à
caporal-chef tomber en opération et mans
pour la france dans l'essentiel combat
contre le terrorisme djihadiste au sahel
je veux en votre nom à tous sur et leurs
familles de notre profonde quand la
profonde compassion et des gants
doléances du sénat ce soir on observe
non seulement sur le sur le site du
figaro mais également
dans les commentaires alexis énormément
de réaction d'émotion et on observe
également dans les réactions politiques
est ce que c'est ça qui vous frappe ou
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres choses qui vous
fera cette danse qui ne sait pas c'est
la façon dont on le vit en france qui
fera pas vraiment parce qu'il faut
penser ce qui se passe
g après la réaction limitée comment dire
n est pas très étonnante
ça fait quand même longtemps et ont fort
heureusement que les différents partis
politiques etc la nation et que les
différentes opinions différentes
obédiences est capable de s'unir autour
d'autres de ses soldats donc c'est
heureux c'est nécessaire ça me paraît
pas extraordinairement inhabituel
comment alors il ya quelques ici ou là
quelques j'ai vu que des insoumis
critique elle les opérations françaises
au mali et dans toute cette zone du zèle
chose qui peut d'ailleurs se discuter
c'est sûrement pas le jour de le faire
mais comment dire le face à des hommes
qui kiffent qui sont prêts parce que
c'est leur métier à faire le sacrifice
de leurs billes qui tombent au combat
même si c'est pas sous le feu
directement c'est dans une opération
militaire et nos opérations de combat
qui dans laquelle il était engagé
il sait leur métier ils sont prêts à
faire ça mais c'est normal aussi que la
nation se recueillent et le rendent
hommage barbara le faire est ce que le
l'engagement et le sacrifice des soldats
au sahel
c'est pas quelque part un peu
l'antithèse de cette génération vous
avez
des cris entre les cadres de l'état
d'esprit de cette génération d'écrivains
génération jeunes bourreaux oui ce qui
est sûr c'est que l'engagement de nos
armées sur sur ces opérations
extérieures
elle engage la france elle engage la
patrie et c'est dans ce sens là qu'on
doit lire leurs engagements maintenant
je crois que les problématiques qu'on
peut avoir avec un certain une certaine
partie très importante aujourd'hui des
nouvelles générations c'est qu'ils ont
justement du mal à s'engager et à se
percevoir dans cette ce projet
patriotique ça ça ça pose un véritable
problème mais pendant longtemps il faut
quand même pas oublier non plus que
l'armée la défense a est servi aussi à
des projets éducatifs bien souvent le
retour de l'armée comme étant dans sa
mission combattante
c'est les années 2 après le 11-septembre
en fait mais toutes les années 90 on
avait un discours d'ailleurs même les
campagnes de publicitaire pour rejoindre
l'armée s'était tu veux être éducateur
sportif rejoint l'armée tu veux être
coiffeur rejoint l'armée on était sur
une communication qui n'était pas
vraiment une communication qui était au
coeur du métier de militaire et là
effectivement depuis une quinzaine
d'années une vingtaine d'années on est
revenu sur le coeur de métier de nos de
nos soldats qui est d'aller combattre et
d'aller combattre pour qu'ils allaient
combattre pour la france parce que c'est
ça qui est important aujourd'hui et
c'est peut-être cela aussi alors
j'entends que vous vous reprocher un
petit peu aux insoumis de d'évoquer déjà
parce qu'effectivement c'est peut-être
un petit peu tôt on est encore dans dans
la douleur et surtout dans la dans la
compassion à l'égard des familles mais
il faut effectivement se demander si on
regarde nos 53 morts au liban en 83
c'étaient des jeunes hommes assassinés
par le hezbollah
le hezbollah est toujours là il est plus
fort que jamais à us bean en 2008
nos dix hommes y sont morts parce qu'ils
avaient été ton biz et est tombé dans un
guet-apens des talibans les talibans
sont toujours là et à chaque fois on a
en face de nous une poignée à côté de la
puissance de l'armée française
aujourd'hui on peut effectivement se
demander si nos quatre mille cinq cents
hommes qui ont à gérer un espace plus
grand que l'europe sont vraiment à même
de venir à bout de cette ce que le
président république a parlé une hydre
mais c'est plus qu'une ivre dans la
région du sahel c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement compliqué et on le voit
bien là ils poursuivent et un pick up et
des hélicoptères
un accident gravissime pour poursuivre
un pick up donc on voit bien quand même
qu'il ya une problématique qui se pose
là qui est problématique aussi de
l'engagement politique puisque c'est
l'état qui engage nos hommes qui engage
nos troupes
alors on a un certain nombre
d'internautes qui réagissent justement
sur les raisons de cette opération dont
caussels notamment flavien qui soldats
et qui en faveur l'opération barkan il
invite toutes les personnes à regarder
des documentaires sérieux qui explique
les raisons de l'engagement français
dans ses régions eh bien justement ça
tombe bien puisque il y en a un qui a
été fait par figaro live par avec tanguy
berthemet nicolas barotte et aziliz le
corps et qui explique pourquoi le
désengagement français au sahel est très
compliqué aujourd'hui est très compliqué
de l'envisager edouard philippe à dakar
la semaine dernière christophe de voogd
évoqué l'idée d'un plus grand soutien
des pays européens mais euh c'est pas
leur front principal leurs ennemis ici
la fin trucs avant les français la
menace les plus tôt au sud
écoutez moi je j'aimerais bien que avec
d'abord qualifié et raison et alexis
brézet raison sur l'unanimité nationale
j'ai toujours un peu peur en france
surtout que je regarde les réseaux
sociaux et il n'y a pas que du lac aux
doléances
oui c'est comme la france officielle
voilà mais cela dit il ya on sent bien
une émotion qui est qui et plus grande
qu'elle n'aurait été peut-être il ya
quelques années là je vais te sens de ce
que dit barbara lefebvre
pour ce qui est de l'aspect
géostratégiques que vous évoquez je
crois que peut-être que en effet nous
sommes totalement dans une situation où
le dispositif est sous-dimensionné 4500
hommes
ça va faire 4500 au petit point dans le
désert et nous constatons quand même que
partout les djihadistes d'al offensive
et notamment dans un pays qui est en
train de basculer qui est le burkina
faso et moi j'ai l'impression que le
premier ministre totalement raison mais
là il faudrait peut-être que le le
président de la république qui appelle
vous savez à une europe plus forte
concentre ses efforts sur cette question
de la défense et d'intervention
européenne parce que c'est peut-être
leur franc le front sud mais le front
sud non seulement la france mais de
toute l'europe
et franchement c'est pas c'est pas
évident je me suis bien d'accord d'aller
convaincre du néerlandais ou des danois
de la question mais croyez moi la cour
la prise de conscience progresse parce
que partout il ya les mêmes
problématiques notamment en matière de
djihadistes de terrorisme et je pense
que la france pour elle a véritablement
s'investir totalement plutôt que
d'affronter 550 sujet européen
puisqu'elle est crédible en matière
européenne
d'autant que vous le savez la grande
bretagne ne sera plus avec nous bientôt
donc je pense qu'il faut véritablement
mettre l'accent là dessus de rien faire
tout ça frédéric dabi d'abord peut-être
un premier commentaire sur justement
l'état de l'opinion et la classe
politique sur la rai les réactions à cet
événement est peut-être le soutien
justement
l'opération barkan et peut-être des
l'état de l'opinion sur 7 sur ces
questions clairement l'opinion publique
soutient l'opération barkan
comme elle l'a soutenu dès le début
l'opération serval n'oublions pas que
dans un seul dans l'océan d'impopularité
reconnais tout à fait parce que je le
genre je viendrai le but de guerre la
finalité était moins bien comprise
n'oublions pas que en janvier 2013
dans un moment extrêmement compliqué
pour le président hollande il connaît un
regain de popularité
bien sûr fugace mais réels liés à
l'opération du manidem qui avait parlé
comme le plus beau jour de sa vie
politique
tout simplement parce que la finalité de
l'opération vous peut bien sûr discuter
ça vous dimitri la part de la france par
rapport aux soldats européens
c'est contenir la poussée jihadistes et
donc ça la finalité est extrêmement
comprises quand les projets
d'intervention en syrie en 2013 ou dans
d'autres théâtres de guerre et est bon
quand même bien compris par les français
à cela il ya deux éléments qui
confirment l'évolution dont parlait
baballe fait 28 à l'heure d'une part une
image extrêmement positive de l'armée
française comme institution qui apparaît
à tort ou à raison - crise que d'autres
piliers de la république
j'ai pas dit qu'elle va mieux j'ai dit
qu'elle aime en crise l'école l'hôpital
notamment qui je dirais mobilise
beaucoup les français et puis
deuxièmement un nouveau regard des
français sur les questions
internationales pour être un peu
schématique par le passé c'était des
catégories éduquer des catégories
sociales supérieures diplômés qui
s'intéressait à ces questions là le
chemin que font beaucoup de français
c'est ces questions qui paraissent
lointaines peuvent nous impacter
directement et je pense que de ce point
de vue là il ya un avant et un après
ce serait d'ailleurs très important que
ces questions de politique étrangère
soit un peu plus travaillé en france
notamment quand on voit la campagne à
chaque fois présidentielle c'est un
sujet qui n'est jamais présent dans la
campagne alors que ce sont des sujets
majeurs
même aujourd'hui voilà même eux mêmes
aux européennes alors que c'est vraiment
fondamental nous
nos élèves n'arrivent même pas à
comprendre le sens de ces opex de ses
engagements extérieurs et justement
certains peuvent aller leur dire vous
voyez on va s'engager pour aller soit
pillé c'est ce que dit en interne au
delà voilà donc s'arrêter là pour quoi
les français au mali nous protègent ils
étaient là pour protéger les intérêts
économiques c'est tout mais alors
justement avec la vidéo d'un artiste que
personnellement j'admire beaucoup qui
est salif kéita je ne comprends pas bien
ce qui lui a pris mais il a fait il ya
quelques jours une vidéo très relayée
sur facebook pour dire il parlait
d'ailleurs en bambara il s'adressait
directement au président au président
biya langue parlée au sud là où il a la
langue du mali et il lui disait pourquoi
est-ce que tu obéis à ce petit macron
c'est un gamin tu sais très bien que
c'est la france qui finance les les
ennemis de nos enfants et c'est vrai que
l'armée malienne
il ya encore peu de temps plus d'une
centaine de soldats maliens en une nuit
ont été massacrés par des djihadistes
dans la région du au nord de gao et
c'est donc eux-mêmes subissent les
foudres des de ces djihadistes et ont
l'impression que les français finalement
ne les aide pas vraiment donc même au
mali il ya une dans un climat politique
en plus très tendue avec un nouveau
premier ministre qui pose enfin qui
essaient de faire une ouverture
gouvernemental c'est des problématiques
très importante or on voit bien que la
culture la culture géo politique
française est très faible je dire dans
l'opinion
et ça il me semble que cocasse quand
même elles progressent a des effets
direction c'est donc c'est d'ailleurs
peut-être le seul point positif que je
vois au nouveau bac c'est cette
spécialité géopolitique après je ne sais
pas si les collectes sont capables de la
deûle abriter mais ce que je crois mais
si ça ça s'il ya une relative unanimité
de la société française qui s'expriment
qui a acquis officiellement au qui a
voix au chapitre
il ya toujours une passe et une partie
de l'opinion qui est en dissidence c'est
vrai on va pas refaire la sphère des
quartiers perdus titre a donc nommé en
tout cas si à cette relative unité dans
qui est qui avait pas dans les années 60
et 70 contre l'armée française le
colonialisme ça c'était pas c'est ce que
raconte notre consoeur les abeilles
lasserre derrière van schendel bien que
le réveil des révolutions du côté de
cette france là c'est aussi que près
peut-être aussi parce que ces sujets ne
sont plus considérés comme des petits
de politique étrangère à partir du
moment où quand on dit bah le
effectivement le drakkar 83 c'est
l'islam l'islamisme radical les us been
2008 ce sont les tableaux ans messieurs
radical aqmi aujourd'hui c'est
l'islamisme radical et qui tape en
france dans les attentats que nous
savons c'est miser radical salle il ya
un moment où le but est allé se fait et
donc pour les gens c'est plus que c'est
plus une note mais c'est plus une opex
c'est plus une opération et qui du coup
parce qu'elle est extérieur serait
toujours suspecte de colonialisme nenê
au collège les gens disent c'est
finalement c'est bon c'est face à un
péril qui guette on est engagé là bas
comme on est engagés ici après est-ce
qu'on a les moyens là bas de le faire
reculer ça c'est une autre affaire ça
c'était donc c'était l'autre question je
voulais vous poser c'est que par rapport
justement à l'enjeu que ça représente
est-ce que 4500 soldats c'est suffisant
ou est ce qu il va pas falloir penser à
un moment ou à renforcer le dispositif
mais le dispositif il est déjà presque à
son maximum
c'est pratiquement 1% du budget de la
défense qui est engagée dans l'opération
barkan c'est un million d'euros par jour
donc c'est des sommes considérables pour
des résultats qui sont vus de loin qui
nous semblent microscopiques mais c'est
quand même une digue que nos armées
tiennent à tout à l'heure
christophe parler des britanniques
malgré le break site
il reste quand même nos meilleurs
partenaires même si son faible c'est
quand même les seuls qui ont quand même
quand même encore un peu le courage de
venir nous soutenir dans le sahel et
toute la philosophie on sait mille
exemples prouvent que c'est atrocement
difficile c'est d'essayer d'organiser le
retrait progressif de nos armes et la
montée en puissance des armées locales
du mali du burkina etc
voilà c'est ce qu'on appelle le g5 sel
apparemment ça marche pas très bien
tout le monde sait qu'à chaque fois
qu'on est allé maritalement il faut être
honnête cette fois qu'on a ici j'ai dit
quand les américains aussi au vietnam ça
peut marcher quand il aussi en
afghanistan ça peut marcher
quand tu es ici en irak ça peut marcher
chaque fois que quand on dit ça on n'y
arrive pas tout seul on va organiser des
troupes locales qui vont prendre leur la
relève
vérité oblige à dire que jusqu'à présent
c'est pas il faut quand même le dire on
a ouvert et là sans fin on a fait on a
créé une situation catastrophique dans
une des frontières qui est la libye veut
dire si aussi l'état libyen a été
fracassée comme il l'a été et ça c'est
une action de la politique française
c'est aussi c'est notre mission d'aller
au moins essayer d'éviter que cette
énième digue saute pour la zone
sahélienne vu qu'on a quand même
participé un petit peu la
déstabilisation via la libye dame au
renforcement éventuel tête du dispositif
ou peut-être un plus grand budget pour
les armes et justement pourquoi pouvoir
ramener ce genre d'opération sera un
soutien dont je pense que nos soutiens
serait possible compte tenu de la
finalité qui est extrêmement clair et
cette notion de digue face à l'islamisme
et c'est vrai que c'est une ce que
rappelait alexis brézet c'est une ça
fait sens chez beaucoup de français ça
fait système avec ce point commun qui
est à 10 l'islamisme radical quasi
systématiquement sur les théâtres
d'opérations extérieures c'est vrai que
la critique des insoumis qui est
peut-être un peu prématuré voire
indécente porte plus chez les français
sont relativement opposé là dessus on
parler de ce qui était colonialiste et
post colonialiste n'oublions pas que
chaque opération militaire extérieure
porté par des présidents de la
république ont été très fortement
soutenue de kolwezi sous giscard
d'estaing ou bien sûr la première guerre
du golfe pour françois mitterrand
mavericks oblige à dire c'est que ce
sont des ce sont des troubles de métier
ses terres sur le demander aux français
on dit on va vous voyez bien sûr ans là
bas je sais pas comment ça va tirer des
francaise voila sur sa skoda il faut
quand même bien voir que on était parti
pour six mois
rappelez vous quand même c'est ce que
dit d'ailleurs la chine marquant le but
c'était de sauver bamako maintenant six
ans et je nuance toujours un peu sur la
libye parce que la libye justement
peut-être un des problèmes c'est qu'on
est parti au bout d'un an et on n'est
pas resté six ans en libye donc je crois
que dans cette affaire tout simplement
nous sommes tranquilles
il faut quand même position c'est qu'il
fallait aller en libye il fallait pas y
aller faut y rester
on a fait on a fait voilà il fallait pas
se laisser raconter des histoires par
les soi disant démocrate des colloques
parisien de saint germain des prés
obliger quelqu'un en particulier
on va pas refaire le débat sur la ville
si on était sûr du mali est en tout cas
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas y aller
tout seul
enfin c'est ça nous dépasse maintenant
et non seulement une question d'argent
mais même du point de vue opérationnel
combien la france pourrait maintenir de
troupes je dirais de façon
opérationnelle effective pas beaucoup
plus que ce qu'on a actuellement
donc il faut parce qu'on est aussi sur
d'autres théâtres d'opération nous
n'oublions pas on est on est encore
ailleurs
donc je crois que c'est vraiment
l'occasion peut-être de sortir par le
haut et la vraie vie ta ble ment de
poser la question de confiance à nos
alliés européens je ne suis pas certain
mais personnellement je ne suis pas du
tout convaincu
vous n'êtes pas du tout comme quoi que
personne ne nous suivraient vous pensez
que des européens absolue mettrait des
trous oui les allemands mais il ya déjà
des néerlandais sur place dire que notre
présent avec 6 prises il ya déjà des
noms mais d'accord mais l'engagement des
européens dans cette affaire il ya des
restrictions dont il ya des destructions
d'emplois des estoniens ils ont payé le
prix aussi oui non mais ça s'organise
mais je dis je dis que encore une fois
plutôt que de faire des grandes
déclarations nouvel économiste sur
toutes les impasses sur le dire que
notre présence au mali est
principalement liée à des intérêts c'est
un peu caricatural dit babineau en
réponse notamment un panda qui dit que
le but de l'opération était de protéger
nos réserves d'uranium situé au niger je
propose d'ailleurs de revenir à 7 sur ce
sur ce débat demain à 11 heures dans les
digues dans les décrypteurs honduras a
et le mali à quoi sert l'opération
barque année est ce que la france doit
continuer sera un débat entre le colonel
michel goya et serge michel off qui a
écrit le livre ça et listant et puis
vous pouvez retrouver le sujet des
églises le corps sur figaro live sahel
la possible retrait de l'armée française
point d'interrogation